we're back I'm sitting here with Will
Ferrell and there are some aspects of
the movie we haven't discussed
[Applause]
[Applause]
you guys work for me what great work
guys great work okay we've got
everything here we've got a whole barber
set up if you want a bib yes I'd like a
bib we got the blue stuff you got the
blue hell yeah okay you're a little hit
of that
I'll take a little folder
[Applause]
oh I brought some brought some reading
material for you bunch of Playboy's from
70s
these are real these are vintage 1970s
Playboy's yeah take a look in there
you're not gonna find anything shaved in
there
[Applause]
miss miss August more like mr. entire
pubic region when you are grooming see
that right there that's the dark forest
from which no man returns these are my
clippers I call it X Cala beard caliber
yes Cala beard
yeah with a D yeah it was forged from a
single piece of steel by renowned
Japanese Clipper Smith Michiko Kakutani
okay are you are you ready to feel the
skin okay at this point I think maybe I
am I think I'm ready to feel this deal
yeah how about you Excalibur are you
ready to serve me in this noble quest
what's that
Excalibur I'm dragging this out too much
[Applause]
and I should just get on with it fine
fine
final Makonnen this is not
battery-powered it runs on pure
righteousness oh okay I have some shave
options for you I'll just show them to
the loader it had a pillar there's the
line okay gay illusionists yeah Hitler
which one would you like I don't want to
eat you know what it doesn't matter okay
here we go
just relax my friend yes oh it's coming
off real smooth
[Music]
it's very strange feeling I have right
now it's gonna do circular motion okay
is anything coming off it doesn't can't
tell how professionally this is being
what distrust Makonnen I'm a
professional how's this look everybody's
in the car I am rock hard right
[Applause]
it's it's all going in my mouth have you
ever done it have you do you have any
expertise at this have you ever done
anything like this before I've always
shaved dogs before and I've done some
pre surgery shavings do you really have
a plan do you really have just just
relax my friends just kick back
just let the blade flow over you
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
no you can't do any better than that
that's horrible and look at my why don't
you give me a bib
it's better than that
my job is done
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
all right well will for all I guess I
can't thank you enough we are gonna win
the commercial break I think we have a
professional here who's gonna clean this
up no I killed him
[Applause]
you